the the next uh issue
um is
uh
that we talk about
um the inhuman nature of bitcoin okay we
talk about the fact that it's not
affected by humans right like it's not
controlled like the fed that's your
that's your main concern look what the
fed's doing pumping out more and more
money it's inflationary this is a
disaster uh the uh bitcoin is not
affected by humans i've heard that and
that's also the one of the most
outrageous egregious things i i could
ever imagine because at least right now
maybe it wasn't so much affected by
humans in the first eight years of its
life cycle but in 2021 baby
i could tie what elon musk said what
china did when they shut down their
machines i could tie every single news
data points to where bitcoin went and so
to me it's like you guys say that this
is a
the benefit is it's it's it's non-human
and then all of a sudden i'm thinking
well it's a hell of a lot more human
manipulated than the dollar so so think
about this for a second
there's two different ways to look at
this conversation let's start with the
monetary policy the structure of it
nobody controls it nobody can change it
no one's ever changed it no one will
ever change it because everyone would
have to agree or majority of people have
to agree so the structure the monetary
policy is immune to human emotions of
greed fear politics etc what you're
talking about is the u.s dollar exchange
price
right which basically means bitcoin was
worth 60 000 now it's worth 40 000. in a
world that is denominated in dollars
there is volatility there's also
volatility in dollars right if you were
to to invert it and say okay the dollar
denominated in bitcoin has been crashing
aggressively for a decade now in the
last 12 months
wait can i stop yeah crap crashing
aggressively so you talk a lot i'm gonna
let you go uh you talk a lot about
america
which to me
i understand your sponsors are in
america this is an american audience
but like i totally get bitcoin in
nicaragua and argentina i mean god i
mean they got they got nothing the bank
means nothing
you know but in america like it's it's
it to me it doesn't even if there's
inflation it doesn't seem like it's a
foregone conclusion that inflation and
bitcoin are
uh are are related or in in any way uh
nor does it seem to me that like we are
headed to a point where bitcoin is going
to become the next uh currency and
replace fiat so all right let me let me
get through a couple of these things
right so first is in the united states
the financial position of americans is
way worse than anyone understands 78 of
americans live paycheck to paycheck
45 of americans have no investable
assets so they're the people who get
hurt the most by the inflation right
stanley druckenmiller has gone on cnbc
multiple times and said listen the fed
is the greatest contributor to wealth
inequality because when they print money
people who hold assets get richer right
everyone that we know that holds assets
has gotten rich beyond their wildest
dreams in the last 12 15 months stock
market hitting all-time highs you know
all that type of stuff bitcoin as well
every asset goes up
the people who get hurt are the people
who live paycheck to paycheck and have
all of their wealth in cash so what you
get is this massive divergence in the
two kind of uh populations if you will
and so ultimately what happens is don't
think of bitcoin as replacing the dollar
from a uh the government is going to ask
me to pay in bitcoin for tax purposes
for right now right just simply think
about it isn't that isn't that the main
point to when the hodler's holders uh
decide to really is it it out of all the
things but here's the reach the thing
and the flow and it's on the third time
i'm gonna hit it at the high and i'm
like it's so obvious why would any if
everyone knows that you're hitting it
the high of the next half what's the
deal it's like jerry seinfeld okay but
but what i don't i just don't understand
like how that how it works all right all
right hold on hold on so so think about
this is uh your grandparents my
grandparents my great grandparents would
tell you and i
save that was that was the advice
financially right was spend less than
you make stay out of debt and save and
before 1971 you literally could save
your way to financial security right
that was possible because there wasn't a
massive devaluation of the currency
today it is impossible to save right if
you look at uh somewhere like a chipotle
where they gave a three to four percent
wage increase to their workers
cpi is at five plus percent right so it
doesn't even account for the actual
inflation and so you can't save your way
so what has happened is we've seen all
these investors push further and further
out on the risk curve they're yoloing
into stocks collectibles bitcoin
cryptocurrency everything that is like
the madness of the markets is because
people can't simply just buy bonds or
hold cash right and so when you get to
that world
it's almost this crazy thing where we
ask a teacher to go to school and be a
great teacher and then go home and be a
professional investor right that's the
only way to keep your purchasing power
which is insane you think it's insane
everyone thinks that's insane
what bitcoin provides is basically a
savings account it's an asset where you
simply just save and as you save what
happens is because of that structure and
that finite uh component to it the u.s
dollar exchange price has to go up as
long as as long as there is more and
more people that want it now what is the
most interesting part about the bitcoin
market i don't know if you know this or
not but you can see on chain which is
basically that open ledger how many
bitcoin are being held by people who
historically have never sold
and that number is usually over 50
percent so right now there's 18 to 19
million there's about 19 million bitcoin
or so in circulation it's like 18.8
million i think and that 18.8 million in
the last 12 months
is held by 70 of that is held by people
who don't sell they're called strong
hands
so you literally have 18.8 million in
the market but 70 percent of them or so
are being held by people who are those
long-term hodlers and so when
institutions or public companies show up
and say hey i want to buy bitcoin they
go to these exchanges and they say hey
i'll pay you ten thousand dollars for
your bitcoin and the bitcoiners say i'm
not selling it then they say fifteen
thousand i'm not selling twenty thirty
so
this also drives me nuts right so you
have it will only go up the demand will
only go up so so it's going to only go
up and then it's the hodler's holders
again i'm not beholden to these economic
textbooks okay but no one's ever said
that you should always hold over time
why did i sell my baseball cards in
february and it just turned out that it
was three days away from what was the
high in the market because it just
seemed too obvious for me i was
uncomfortable the idea of holding is a
cult-like activity that in previous
worlds just does not make any economic
sense and is unique to this bitcoin
crypto market which to i think a
rational person like myself makes
absolutely no sense okay so it's a fair
critique let me put it in a different
perspective and i think it'll make more
sense if i said to you name a meme stock
the first one that you would tell me is
gamestop amc one one of the ones that
we've recently talked about i would
argue that berkshire hathaway is a meme
stock right there is a leader warren
buffett people go on mecca to omaha
every year to talk to him they are
disciples
it has cultish
properties i agree with you so berkshire
hathaway amc same story different
generations it's not it's not the same
story because amc everyone knows that
the popcorn is still ingrained in their
red carpet from 1983 and they know that
and they know that while warren buffett
has said buy what you know
he has done some great deals with
insurance companies and transportation
there is actually fundamentals behind it
i'm talking about the the psychological
component i got various properties of it
i get it okay so those are very similar
just different generations
historically people would buy real
estate and would say never sell the real
estate the real estate will always go up
in value because it's actually the
dollar being devalued against it right
now what these people are doing is ahead
it's a hedge yeah as huddlers is they're
basically buying digital real estate as
a way to look at it so there's 21
million lots
in this digital ledger
how many do you own right and so just
like you wouldn't sell the real estate
or day trade the real estate or say hey
you know what i think it's high in
february let me buy it back in march
right because it just doesn't make sense
to do that with real estate the same
thing's happening here and so ultimately
one of the things that bitcoiners say
which uh
this is going to be crazy for you to
hear at first but just think through it
for a second
oh i've heard a lot of crazy bitcoin
bitcoin actually embodies
the timeless investing principles it's
basically dollar cost average in
don't look at price and sell
and hold for really really long periods
of time and if you buy a great asset and
hold it for a long period of time you
will do well when it comes to wealth
generation but see the problem is
bitcoin is so young that it that that's
why it comes off as a tactic real estate
is not young bitcoin is and so it's like
oh it's look look let me show you the
chart of the last 10 years how can you
argue with this it's the last 10 years
and it's the first 10 years and and i
can show you a chart and i know it's the
first 10 so it means a little bit more
the first 12 whatever that chart is but
i can show you a beautiful chart of
of blockbuster from 1985 to 1995. so
here is a a great way to look at it in
1971 is the creation of fiat currency
and that fiat currency is only 50 years
old right we just had the 50 year
anniversary of brent of uh the nixon uh
speech bitcoin is 12. so it's younger
than uh the fiat currency if you look in
1971 at what happened to gold it was at
like 35 bucks or whatever and now it's
trading at you know 16 1700 so there's
the world repriced gold once it was
unpacked
my belief is that the world at that time
was trying to price what is a global
store of value right and so gold was a
global store of value it ended up
pricing it where it is today i think
bitcoin's going through the same thing
which is in the first 12 years it
explodes you're not going to get the
same returns in the next 12 years that
you got in the first 12 years obviously
right there's more uh distributed
ownership all that type of stuff but
what i do think is that bitcoin which
historically has grown at let's say 200
percent compound annual growth for a
decade maybe that comes down and it's
150 or 100 or whatever the number is
itself but it could be negative it could
be zero i mean like well the only way
that it would be zero is that you would
have to basically have no more
increasing demand so the whole thing is
it is possible even though bitcoin
itself is not replaceable to the exact t
right you i buy that you cannot replace
bitcoin to to the computer systems how
everything's back-ended fine but maybe
there is something that is like that
that people simply want you always talk
about you know the digital currency the
quick transaction on the ledger if that
did become a currency and we did more of
that like
i don't know like i know i'm a 43 year
old guy but like
i kind of like the 100 days where i can
get my money back on on apple payer and
i know you you you can say well well
then we'll pay if there's a problem
we'll pay you back and it's a it's it's
the it's the young fast transactions but
like again like it seems to me and i
know we're we're we're almost done here
it seems to me that
people say if they're in bitcoin or
crypto they say it's not comparable to
anything
except when they when it is convenient
to compare so there's definitely tons of
what i'll call uh intellectual
manipulation that goes on because people
are trying to explain it they're trying
to compare it uh there's also a spectrum
of people who are very sophisticated and
can explain it well and then those who
are trying their best et cetera right so
like that's true in any market
what i would say is the comparison
between bitcoin let's say apple pay is a
comparison of technologies from a
payments perspective what the true
bitcoiners i think wrap their head
around and kind of hold on to is bitcoin
is different from a monetary policy
standpoint so forget for a second which
transaction is faster or you know does a
store accept apple pay or not whatever
the difference is the 180 degree um kind
of opposite is the spectrum of bitcoin
being a transparent programmatic
monetary policy versus an unpredictable
one and so ultimately what you have to
do is you have to get to from a sequence
of events you can't be a true good
medium of exchange unless first you're a
good store of value you can't be a true
good medium or a store value unless you
are a super secure decentralized system
in today's digital world and so what i
think is going to happen here is these
central bank digital currencies this is
you know the digital dollar et cetera
those are technology innovations but the
monetary policy is the exact same
right what bitcoin did was it innovated
on monetization it's not possible to
have will it be possible to have a
centralized obviously it won't run
exactly as bitcoin but will it is it
possible that a replacement is a
centralized coin so what i think ends up
happening is every single country in the
world that has a fiat currency is going
to create a digital version so there
will be a digital dollar digital euro
digital juan et cetera is doing that
right they're all doing it the the
problems with that i think there's three
problems one is you drastically increase
uh financial surveillance right now if i
want to know what's in your bank account
i got to go to a fisa court or whatever
and get an order to subpoena your bank
records right if they control the system
they can see in your account in which
everything you spend on really scary
stuff especially in authoritarian
countries but even here in the u.s the
second thing is that they can
personalize the monetary policy so
everything in your life is personalized
your news feed your search results your
music playlist your google maps
everything if all of a sudden i can say
darren gets a high rate of inflation and
pomp doesn't
or darren has to uh you know experience
something from a monetary policy
standpoint and pomp doesn't scary the
third thing is uh and china just ran a
test here and we have it in the u.s with
ebt cards is what if they make the money
expire so say we're going to move to a
ubi system and every month darren's
going to get 1200
but he must spend it in the first 30
days or it disappears
now all of a sudden you lose sovereignty
right you lose control it becomes a more
authoritarian system and so all of that
will be possible i'm not saying that
they're gonna do it okay i agree
that makes sense but also
some people are more comforted in an
authoritative system than a system that
has nothing and no one running it uh
agreed whatever we got a minute i got
two more things i am not going to invest
in bitcoin yet i mean this would take
another couple hours but my two last
things and i'll leave the floor to you
for the for the last bit you talk about
inflation
and the one thing about inflation that
people think about is erratic volatility
and it isn't bitcoin at least in the
last six to ten months more erratic than
the american dollar
and that's one and then two
why do you feel the need why do all
people who invest in bitcoin feel the
need that they need to talk about it and
pump it up why is it part of like a
multi-level marketing scheme why is that
part of the deal when i buy bitcoin why
do i have to pump it up why does pomp on
on june 26 2019 say there's a 75 percent
chance that it's going to reach 100 000
by 2021 why is there that need that's my
final thing all right
inflation
inflation dollars guaranteed to go down
in value guaranteed there's not very
many things guaranteed in life
guaranteed dollar will lose value every
single year second thing on inflation is
that if you look over the last six seven
months bitcoin has appreciated it was
thirty thousand dollars on january first
and now it's sitting at forty five forty
six thousand dollars the dollar has been
devaluing so over twelve months six
months ten years five years everything
the dollar has gone down bitcoin has
gone up in value so bitcoin protects and
increases your purchasing power
while the dollar does the exact opposite
two completely different uh kind of
structured systems
you want to throw up every day from you
know the roller coaster uh agreed if you
look at the us dollar price now what we
didn't get to maybe we'll do a you know
a different conversation around is if
all of a sudden everything is priced in
the currency so dollars you don't
realize that the dollar is volatile you
just see that oh prices went up a little
bit right that's the only way you see
any level of inflation you don't realize
that the dollar lost 10 15 20 percent
there's not a there's not a metric every
day on how
exactly right so
if everything was denominated in bitcoin
you wouldn't see us dollar exchange val
you know uh uh price volatility you
would just see whether the price of
things are going up or down over the
last 10 years everything's been getting
cheaper if you denominate your life in
bitcoin everything getting more
expensive in dollars so let's put that
in the box and we'll put that to the
side the second thing is i think most
people who hold bitcoin what ends up
happening i say it all the time is
bitcoin taught me economics and it
taught me personal finance i got an
economics degree i didn't learn anything
in college right but i got the degree i
got a piece of paper i'm supposed to
know all this stuff it's not until i
bought bitcoin that i really started to
understand money and there's this belief
that like people come for the profits
they think they're going to get rich
that's what pulls people into bitcoin or
cryptocurrency they think they're going
to get rich
not everyone but a lot of people but
ultimately they start to hold the asset
and they start to learn economics they
have to learn about personal finance
they start to learn about the dollar
bretton woods inflation all these things
and they start to understand wow why was
i not taught this in high school in
college or after i graduated and what
they're doing is they're not so much
talking about bitcoin i think i think
what they're doing is they're actually
talking about calling out kind of the
charade that goes on in the legacy
system now what they say is hey
bitcoin's the solution bitcoin fixes
this you know whatever your your
favorite uh example is but i don't think
it's about talking so much about bitcoin
as it is highlighting the issues in the
legacy system
okay are you gonna buy bitcoin
uh i will buy you know what uh to honor
you for having the balls to have me on
uh i will i will buy some bitcoin i'll
receive it in 10 days because i'm gonna
go through coinbase uh i will buy a
nominal amount of bitcoin um and i will
it will be in your name i will i will
honor you by by by doing that today
because i appreciate you uh having me on
and allowing you to ask some of the
tough questions hey guys thanks so much
for watching that clip of the best
business show make sure you like and
subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it